SPEAKER: There is no higher
form of user validation
than having customers
support your product
with their wallets.
But the path to a
profitable business
is not always an easy one.
To help you choose the
best monetization strategy,
Google and Udacity have
created App Monetization,
an online course that presents
strategies and best practices
on how to make your
apps profitable.
This course includes
viewpoints from e-commerce
to games and insights
from leading start-ups
in multiple industries.
By the end of this
course, you'll
be able to choose and
implement a monetization
strategy relevant
to your product,
set performance
metrics and monitor
the success of a
strategy, and know
when to pivot your existing
monetization strategy.
So what are you're waiting for?
For more information,
visit udacity.com/google.